So what we now do in these
types of processes is
basically kind of start looking
at scales at different octaves.
And this is one of the reasons we
looked at the whole concept of doing
this kind of analysis at
different pyramid levels,
because each one of them
is a different octave.
And now we can actually
start modeling the signal,
and now we can actually start doing all
of the processing and what of course
comes out is the different scales we
can actually have these Gaussians, and
stuff like that, and
using these Gaussians, we can also start
looking at differences of Gaussians.
Again, very similar concept to what
we have done when we did some of
the blending using the frequency domain.
Basically, look at
these types of things,
you can see is that we now
actually can do the pyramids and
start looking at information
at different scales.
This basically shows us how we can
actually do the different Gaussians that
I was showing you before
between different scales.
And using that,
we can find the extrema points,
which are all these examples here.
Of course, what we want to do now is
find a few specific extrema points.
So, of course, we would now kind of find
all the points that have high contrast
and that starts giving me more features.
There's a lot more features here and, of
course, now I've started reducing them.
And then I get rid of all of that are
not edges, just the corner features and
I get even less number of points.
And this starts kind of giving
me the features that I want.